and jim nance
all right aj
ladies and gentlemen we're here with the
national champions the kansas jayhawks
and it's time to receive the
championship trophy
chairman tom burnett
president dr emmerich would you please
present the trophy to coach bill sell
well first of all ladies and gentlemen
let's thank the city of new orleans for
hosting a wonderful tournament and
bringing us all back together again
and second of all the fans the fans here
have been amazing
the university of kansas fan base has
been extraordinary we're so excited for
you
and here to present the trophy is the
head of the basketball committee tom
burnett to coach self in the kansas city
jayhawks university of kansas jayhawks
coach congratulations wonderful job on
behalf of the basketball committee
congrats
[Applause]
hey back down a little bit
back up back up a little bit hey easy
all right remy good job coach everybody
wants to know
what did you say to this team at
halftime when you're down 15. i really
didn't say much
we were disappointed in how we played
the first half carolina was obviously
the much better team
but this team has been down before and
uh
you know i told him at halftime would
you rather be down 15 with 20 left or
down nine with two left because that was
obviously what happened in 2008 and they
all said let's take 15. so we played off
of that
you know i thought about your team
tonight
about what you guys did in the regional
final now you didn't have a big deficit
but you turned the switch in that game
in chicago against miami it was very
similar to what happened here tonight
wasn't it well we uh we didn't play well
the first half against miami and then we
were lights out the second half and
tonight we obviously labored the first
half but the kids competed we still
didn't make free throws we missed some
bunnies but that's about as good
defensively i think a team can play uh
that second half you know brown came up
big in that second half i mean i hate to
isolate any players mccormick david you
hit some big shots on a couple of trips
down the floor in the lake going that
was huge too wasn't it oh yeah we had uh
we had some really good possessions late
we posted cb a couple of times and
and everybody contributed uh everybody
played well
but we when we had to have a basket we
went to big dave and he delivered what
does it mean to you
to have now a second national
championship you are the first kansas
coach in history to have multiple
national titles the first ever
you've done that now you said you wanted
more in a press conference this week
you've got it what does it mean
well it means that kansas has won a
fourth national championship is what it
basically means and
it's great for the kids uh
it's especially special for my family
this year because you know we we lost
our father uh
two months ago so
we had a lot to play for
congratulations coach i know how much
this one meant in your heart i know i
know it did well done thank you very
much sir coach
[Applause]
all right
christian quick word
i'm looking for ochai also
oh
how about the hand up you had on the
last shot of the game for the attempted
tie yeah still want to foul he got he
got a decent look but you know it felt
good when he missed
your teammate over here and i think it
could have gone to just about
any one of you guys on the jayhawks but
ochai you've been named the most
outstanding player of the final four
congratulations i appreciate that i
appreciate that
oh man this is a special group of guys
we're going down to history all i got to
say is rock chalk baby
you guys realize i'll leave you with
this david
and your teammates may not know it
it's the biggest comeback
in the history of the championship game
you guys will forever have that claim
as the comeback kids how did you do it
i mean kansas is a historical program so
we set another history tonight uh we
just locked in as a as a family as a
team and that's what we do we overcome
the odds we overcome adversity we're
just built for this
congratulations guys there's some nets
ready to be torn down there's one
shining moment that's going to be played
for all of you tonight because you are
the national champions the kansas
jayhawks thank you new orleans a
memorable final four we'll never forget
[Music]
we'll be coming back with ej